في المقدمة الليلة مؤامرة اغتيال بوتين المزعومة
رئيس المخابرات العسكرية الأوكرانية الليلة يقول إن
جهاز الأمن الروسي تم تكليف جهاز الأمن الفيدرالي
بمهمة اغتيال
يفغيني باغوسيان زعيم مجموعة فاغنر
الذي قاد التمرد المسلح
ضد بوتين بالطبع هذا باغوسيان
ورئيس المخابرات الأوكرانية
يقول  اقتبس من كل
محاولات الاغتيال المحتملة هذه لن تكون سريعة،
وسوف يستغرق الأمر بعض الوقت للحصول على
الأساليب المناسبة والوصول إلى المرحلة
التي يكونون فيها على استعداد لإضافة
عملية ضخمة بشكل جيد، البيت الأبيض الليلة
يقول لشبكة CNN إنه ليس متأكدًا مما يفعله
بوتين  الأمر متروك لهذا الأمر ولكننا بالطبع
نعرف ما يحدث للعديد من الذين يعترضون على
بوتين وينتهي بهم الأمر مسمومًا أو مسجونًا أو
ميتًا في كل حالة تقريبًا، فهل سيكون ذلك
مصير بروجسيان؟ كل ما يمكننا أن نقوله لك
الآن هو أنه مفقود
ولم يكن موجودًا  شوهد منذ يوم السبت عندما
أفيد أنه أبرم هذا الاتفاق مع
الكرملين أه أو بالفعل مع لوكاشينكو
زعيم بيلاروسيا لإلغاء
تمرد باغوسيان المسلح منذ ذلك الحين،
إليك ما حدث لقد سجل
شيئًا ما لأه في اليوم التالي تم تسجيله
ولم نره  ثم كانت طائرتان من طائراته
تعبران روسيا متجهتين إلى
بيلاروسيا عائدتين إلى روسيا، ثم اليوم مرة أخرى
كانت إحدى طائراته في طريقها
هذه المرة من موسكو إلى سان
بطرسبرج وكلاهما داخل روسيا، لذلك كان الأمر
مزعجًا على إحدى هذه الطائرات، حسنًا، نحن لا
نفعل ذلك  "لا أعرف بشكل صحيح لأننا لم
نره، إنه لا يتحدث، وتتأكد موسكو من أن
الأمر سيبقى على هذا النحو الليلة،
الوصول إلى المواقع التابعة
للإمبراطورية الإعلامية لعصر ما قبل الولادة، وهذا أمر
مهم حقًا لمحاولة معرفة
ما يحدث، الوصول إلى تلك المواقع
منعت التحذير عندما تشاهد
هذا أن بعض ما أنت على وشك
رؤيته مزعج
الممرضات هنا قاموا هذه المرة ومرة ​​أخرى
بمعالجة الجرحى الجدد من
الجبهة مؤكدين للجنود أنه
على الرغم من الألم سيكونون على ما يرام
بالقرب من المعارك  حول باحمود، أصيب هذا
المستشفى الميداني المعروف باسم نقطة الاستقرار
بعد أن تم ضماداته على عجل من قبل
القتال، المسعفون يتلقون العلاج المناسب الأول
من قبل فريق طبي كامل كان هؤلاء
الجنود يتقدمون عندما
تعرضوا لنيران المدفعية الروسية المكثفة في
نقطة الاستقرار هذه حتى الآن.
استقبل اليوم أكثر من 50 جنديًا
من الجبهة يعانون من شظايا
المدفعية والارتجاجات.
لم يصدر الجيش الأوكراني بيانات عن
الضحايا، أظهر استطلاع حديث أجري هنا
أن ما يقرب من 80 بالمائة من
الأوكرانيين لديهم أقارب أو
أصدقاء مقربين أصيبوا أو قُتلوا
نتيجة لذلك.  بعد الغزو الروسي واسع النطاق،
تفاجأ أندريه، جراح الأوعية الدموية،
بعدم وجود المزيد من الجرحى
حتى خلال هذا الهجوم المضاد،
ويقول إن لدينا خسائر أقل مما
توقعنا بمجرد
تنظيف الجروح ووضع الضمادات،
سيتم نقل الجنود  إلى
مستشفيات مجهزة بشكل أفضل في أماكن أخرى فالنتينو
يدرس التكنولوجيا الحيوية وكييف عندما
بدأت الحرب في 24 فبراير من العام الماضي
وبحلول 26 فبراير بدأت العمل
كممرضة كما تقول ثم عملت في
عيادات الإخلاء والآن عند
نقطة الاستقرار هذه
لا يزال إدوارد في حالة صدمة ولكن  إصابته
خطيرة،
أنا بخير، قال، لكنها تحترق كثيرًا،
أعتقد أنها كانت قطعة من الشظايا،
شيء ما طار بالقرب مني بهذه الطريقة، لقد كنت
محظوظًا لأنها مرت بجانبي،
ولم يكن الجميع هنا محظوظين.